der sicherheitsexperte gustav größe des
bei uns vom european council on foreign
relations begleiten sie uns heute schon
einige ganzen morgen durch diese sendung
es geht vor allen dingen auch darum die
entwicklung in der ukraine und das was
wir gerade gehört haben einzuordnen und
ich würde gerne eine sache aufgreifen
die er gerade gesagt hat der blitzkrieg
ist gescheitert das sehen wir andere der
krieg dauert viel länger als putin das
wahrscheinlich sich selber ausgemalt hat
welche strategie der russischen
streitkräfte sehen sie denn aktuell
also zurzeit versucht man vor allen
dingen den verteidiger zu erwarten in
dem man die städterin greift in dem man
zivilisten an greift das bewusst
vorzuführen dass man sozusagen die
schwachen in der gesellschaft nicht
verteidigen kann deshalb sehen wir auch
so viele angriffe auf krankenhäuser
schulen auf altenheime die
die streitkräfte selber befinden sich in
einer phase der reorganisation sie
halten im grunde das gelände das schon
erobert ist nur um mario pohl und in im
kompass gibt es gibt es ganz beschränkt
geländegewinne sonst ist man statisch
und in der versorgung dass die nach
kommt wegen der versorgungslage wegen
den bisherigen verlusten zahlreiche
dieser verbände die eingesetzt wurden
haben wir so hohe verluste erlitten dass
sie in der alten form nicht mehr
einsatzfähig sind und müssen jetzt mit
anderen wieder gruppe sozusagen zusammen
verschmolzen werden das zweite ist das
natürlich nach dem ersten april also
mitte april ein weiterer ansatz an
russischen kräften erfolgen kann weil
man einfach neue soldaten krieg mit dem
mit dem nächsten einberufungstermin neue
wehrpflichtige in russland die dann alge
wehrpflichtige aus dem aus dem system
entlassen die können vertrags einen
vertrag unterschreiben dass er brennt ja
auch jetzt die propaganda auf hochtouren
und den leuten weiszumachen dass alles
nach plan läuft und die die operation
gerechtfertigt ist damit sich möglichst
viele junge menschen dann freiwillig
melden nach ihrem wehrpflicht um dann in
die ukraine geschickt zu werden und dann
kann man sozusagen es noch einmal
probieren und hinzu kommt ja auch die
meldung der hyperschall waffen die
anscheinend jetzt neu eingesetzt werden
die es das einzuordnen was bedeutet das
für die kriegsführung eigentlich nicht
wenig also russland verwendet
um ziele im westen im westen der ukraine
anzugreifen nur ballistische raketen und
marschflugkörper nimm hyperschall waffen
weil dort die flugabwehr stark ist der
ukraine und auch noch die luftwaffe
einsatzbereit ist das heißt man fliegt
selber nicht einkriegen rein
psychologisch ist es natürlich war es
also man versucht jetzt sozusagen im
westen zu signalisieren diese diese
pause die man sich selber gibt um zu
reagieren um keine um jetzt den westen
sozusagen davon abzuschrecken waffen zu
liefern um die die stimmung möglichst
kippen zu lassen und da sind natürlich
diese hyperschall war von psychologisch
1 1 einen moment und militärisch sagen
sie nicht viel aus wir wissen auch noch
nicht einmal ob sie überhaupt irgendwas
getroffen haben es gibt natürlich im
moment auch sagen wir mal symbolisch
starke zeichen die zum beispiel von
russland eingefordert sind nämlich die
aufgabe von mario polen da hat der
ukrainische präsident gesagt das kommt
nicht infrage begeben nicht auf es gibt
aber einige stimmen die insgesamt ja
auch sagen die ukraine sollte sich
einfach ergeben wenn man waffen liefert
man würde nur den krieg verlängern wie
ordnen sie das ein
also man muss sich nur anschauen wie
russland sich in den besetzten gebieten
verhält beziehungsweise jetzt auch in
mario portmann hat in polen einen nicht
unerheblichen teil der leute die sich
privat auf dem weg machen also ohne
organisierten flucht korridor mit dem
auto
umgeleitet nach russland verteilt dienen
in zentral russischen städten man
spricht von einer säuberung mario pohl
es gibt verhaftungswellen in den
besetzten gebieten
man weiß und teil nicht wo die leute
hinkommen das heißt das blutvergießen
würde aus ukrainischer sicht ja durch
einen durch eine beendigung des
organisierten militärischen widerstandes
nicht enden es würde sich da nur
verlagern vom militärischen
hinzu säuberungen und zu aktionen
russischer sicherheitsminister am
donnerstag trifft sich die nato zu einem
sondergipfel kann man eigentlich sagen
je länger sich dieser krieg jetzt
hinzieht desto größer auch der druck auf
die nato und was bedeutet das für die
entscheidungsfindung auch innerhalb der
nato
ja also nachdem russland der
nuklearmacht ist wird die nato nicht
direkt in den krieg sich sozusagen
direkt einbringen also nicht wie in
jugoslawien wo unter den
flugverbotszonen aufgesetzt hat oder wo
man dann auch un beschlüsse mit
militärischer waffengewalt durchgesetzt
hat das wird es nicht geben aber um die
ukraine unterstützen zu können
brauche es auch sicherheits an der
ostflanke vor möglichen repressalien
oder einer ausweitung oder drohgebärden
das zweite ist wenn wir jetzt nicht das
militärische gerät anschaut dass man der
ukraine zur verfügung stellen kann das
sofort einen unterschied macht dann
sieht das in erster linie waffensysteme
die die ukraine schon kennen an denen
sie ausgebildet sind und die sind
natürlich vorhanden in polen in rumänien
in den baltischen staaten in allen
ehemaligen warschauer pakt
mitgliedstaaten jetzt aber natürlich vor
russland selber auch angst haben wenn
man denen jetzt sagt bitte geht den
ukrainern soviel waffen und gerät wie
möglich da muss irgend wer diese
sicherheitslücke die entsteht hier auch
abfangen und dann sind natürlich andere
westeuropäische staaten die usa in der
pflicht hier in diesen staaten selber
truppen zu stationieren damit die ihre
lager leer räumen können das ein dilemma
und was ein schmaler grat und was man
alles beachten muss vielen dank für ihre
einschätzungen einordnung für heute
danke dass wir uns durch diese sendung
bisher erst mal begleitet haben vielen
dank